So it turns out I have to take a
language,
credit and university,
so I'm going to take the easiest
language in the world.
Good day everyone.
One of the most common questions about
language learning is what is the easiest
language to learn?
Now there is no exact answer to that
question that applies to everyone
because it depends on a few different
factors.
So the factors,
it depends on or your native language,
any other languages you happened to have
learned and also the complexity of the
language in question.
So if your native language is English
than the easiest language for you is
probably the one that's the most similar
to English.
Uh,
and if it's not,
then maybe you've learned another
language.
Like if you've learned French,
then maybe the language that's easiest
for you to learn as the one that's most
similar to French because you've already
learned a lot of the concepts of those
that those languages have in common.
So you've already done a lot of the work
in the past already.
Okay?
So it could be your native language,
the one that's closest to your native
language,
closest to other languages you've
learned,
and it also another factor is the
complexity of that language.
So it could be a language that's similar
to your own,
but if that language happens to be quite
complex,
then maybe that's not the easiest one.
So it's kind of a balance of those
different factors.
So it's.
There's no precise formula,
but we have an idea just from those
factors now the American Foreign Service
Institute that trains American diplomats
to go overseas,
what trains them in language skills
before their placement overseas.
They've done a lot of research into this
topic as it relates to English speakers
because they're training their American
staff to go abroad.
So they're English speakers,
but they're learning other languages.
So they have a lot of data about how
many hours it takes,
about how intensively they have to study
these different groups of languages.
So they have it categorized into four
different groups.
Is Category One,
which are the easiest languages to learn
for native English speakers than they've
got two,
three,
four,
and then five is the.
The group of most difficult languages to
learn and those people studying those
languages study for I believe,
88 weeks full time.
So that's like 88 weeks I guess a year
and a half,
something like that.
Um,
people who study the category one
languages I think are in there for 23 or
24 weeks full time.
So it's almost times four if you learn a
level five language.
So which ones are in level one the
easiest category?
They are uh,
the Germanic languages such as a Dutch
Africans,
the northern Germanic languages from
Scandinavia,
Sweden,
a Swedish or Norwegian and Danish not
finished.
That's separate language group.
And then you've got the romance
languages like French and Spanish,
Italian and Portuguese and I believe
also Romanian is in there.
So those ones are the most closely
related to English.
You've got the dramatic ones like Dutch
and Afrikaans and I think those are
probably the most closely related to
English and the easiest to learn.
I haven't actually studied those
personally,
but a lot of people say that Dutch is
the easiest for English speakers.
I have studied French and French has
been the easiest language that I have
personally studied.
I used to think it was Indonesia because
Indonesia is really simple and really
straightforward and I made really fast
progress in it and I could communicate
an Indonesian after studying for just a
couple of months before a trip.
Uh,
but when I started to study French I
realized how much of an advantage that
shared vocabulary is because English
vocabulary is something like 35 percent
French.
So when I would look at a French text I
would recognize a lot of the keywords
already and I can basically understand
half of the text without ever having
studied French.
So after a few weeks I could basically
read and after a few months I could
communicate and speak not fluently,
but I could make myself understood and I
could understand pretty much whatever
was said to me face to face,
at least not on the radio and not third
person,
but face to face I could understand.
So French has been definitely the
easiest one for me.
Category too,
by the way,
consists of only German.
German is a dramatic language.
Just like that,
sure.
Afrikaans and it's closely related to
English,
but it's also quite complex
grammatically.
It's not that complicated from what I
hear,
but it does have some complications like
a grammatical case endings that,
uh,
other Germanic languages don't have.
And that's why it's not in category one.
It's a little bit more complex than the
category one languages that puts it in
category two.
And I believe it's the only language in
category two,
so it's kind of off on its own because
it's related to English,
but a little bit complicated.
The hardest has been Japanese by far.
Um,
and that's one of the category five
languages according to the Foreign
Service Institute.
Now what makes Japanese so hard is first
of all,
the grammatic grammar is very different
from English.
It's about as different as you can get.
And also the writing system is extremely
complex and I think that the Fsi
categorization of level five doesn't
even take into account.
The writing system is just the spoken
language.
It matches my experience with French
versus Japanese.
It's feel,
it feels to me like it took about five
times as long to get conversant in
Japanese as it did with French,
about five times as long.
But then the writing system on top of
that takes a lot longer than that,
maybe 10 times or 20 times or 30 times,
as long as,
as it takes to learn to read French to
read and write French because it,
you're learning for different,
uh,
writing systems and combining them
together.
You're idiographic pictures.
Those are the Chinese characters.
Congee,
those are very complicated and there's
2000 of them that you need just to read
a book comfortably.
Uh,
and they're read in different ways.
There's different pronunciations for
each one.
So learning Japanese is a real longterm
intensive thing.
So it's been the hardest for me a
second.
So that will be Arabic because when you
learn Arabic you're learning not only
one language,
you're learning the formal language,
which is kind of outdated,
archaic language.
But then you have to learn a dialect at
the same time.
And then you have to learn how to
communicate with speakers of other
dialects.
So with Arabic you're learning a whole
language family,
that's what makes it hard.
Uh,
but the easiest has definitely been
French followed by Indonesian because of
its simplicity.
A Indonesian,
by the way,
is a category three language according
to Fsi.
Obviously it's one of the more simple
languages,
but it doesn't have that shared
vocabulary that with English that French
or Spanish or Italian or,
or Dutch or Africans would have.
That's why it's not in category one,
even though it's very simple.
Anyway,
I hope that was helpful.
I hope that gave you an understanding
and I hope you're not choosing the
language to study just based on how easy
it is.
I hope you are just interested in
getting that information.
All right.
Have a good night.
See you later.